the most hated man in the world right
now may very well be Martin shkreli the
32 year olds pharmaceutical company
bought a one-of-a-kind HIV and cancer
treatment pill and hiked the price up by
five thousand percent for no other
apparent reason than to make money but
then there was the backlash social media
erupted politicians denounced his
practices and shkreli now has said he
will lower the medications price
congrats you guys
you stopped the greedy CEO done and done
right hardly Morra calcine health policy
director at the Center for American
Progress said price gouging in the
pharmaceutical industry is a very common
practice right now I think you're seeing
a perfect storm I think that this is
just the latest example of what people
are seeing is extraordinarily high cost
that are becoming more more and more out
of control and less and less affordable
after acquiring the rights to
tuberculosis medication earlier this
year one company increased the price by
more than 2,000 percent and two separate
life-saving heart medications went up in
price this February by five hundred and
twenty five percent and two hundred and
twelve percent per vial the same day
they were bought by a new company oh and
our friend Martin shkreli he did the
same thing for the last company he
worked for jacking up the price of
kidney medication by two thousand
percent hmm when capitalism and
life-saving meds combined as you can
imagine Americans spend a lot on
prescription drugs three hundred and
seventy four billion dollars last year
alone and yet prices for crucial
prescription medications continue to
rise so how can they get away with
hiking up prices well it's a lack of
regulation the FDA has no rules against
price hikes so companies can take
advantage of owning the only drug on the
market this affects not only people who
pay out-of-pocket
but hospitals and insurance companies
too and then there's the big pharma
Lobby which happens to spend way more
money on lobbying Congress than any
other industry which of course helps
them profit even more
in 2003 they successfully lobbied
Congress to deny Medicare the ability to
negotiate drug prices so Medicare and in
turn all of us pay more
Big Pharma is so lucrative in fact that
companies like Pfizer can afford to pay
billions in fines for promoting drugs
that aren't approved as safe and despite
what CEOs like shkreli say companies
often spend more on marketing their
drugs than on research and development
sometimes twice as much if the status
quo remains it is a win for the
pharmaceutical industry and it's a
little off what consumers so what's
being done well some politicians have
been working more strictly to regulate
the pharma industry both Bernie Sanders
and Hillary Clinton have presidential
plans to regulate drug pricing but big
pharma isn't phased one CEO went on
CNBC's Mad Money this week to say what
he felt about government regulation all
of our intelligence says that that it's
going to be very hard for Hillary or any
other candidate to really have a
profound impact on drug pricing he might
be right about the candidates
but as calcine told us it's public
opinion that could really have sway
especially since 73 percent of Americans
think prescription drug prices are
unreasonable so did the most hated man
in the world finally get us talking
about the big pharma problem
you